What's popping now, as you can see, I'm wearing some warrior swag,
cause you know, I love baseball. What can I say? And you know, Steph Curry,
she's great. She's amazing. Today.
We're going to be talking about LinkedIn and I'm going to be talking about how
to get an internship at LinkedIn as a software engineer. Now,
before you watched this video, I think you should watch the first one.
And the second one that I made,
because I talk about how I got my first internship.
And then I talk about how I got my internship at Citadel,
which actually kind of feeds into how I got this internship,
because with that experience. All right. So without further ado.
Here we go.
Now, before we talk about how I got into chill,
let me just talk to you about the benefits.
Yeah.
When I interned there,
the salary was $45 an hour or $7,800
a month. So it was the same as Citadel, but the housing was less good.
So this time we had to share a two bedroom apartment with four people.
So it was two people in one room. Now at first I thought that was like, kind of,
but I mean, soon I realized like, because of that, we were a lot closer.
So like always, you know, like every other big company there's free breakfast,
free lunch and free dinner, you know, their breakfast was bomb. Honestly.
I think out of all my internships,
their breakfast was the best because you get smoked salmon every day.
Not like other companies that sometimes they either don't have smoked salmon or
they only have smoked salmon, Fridays, Facebook. And of course I have a gym,
but that's a given. All right. So now that you know, that's a pretty dope job.
Let me tell you how I got it or how you can get it.
So let's just look at my resume real quick. All right. So here's my resume now,
as you can see, the work experience has been updated from last time.
This time I have two jobs, I have Citadel and Scotia bank.
Now for the Citadel one, I want to talk about, you know,
my C plus plus experiences, you know,
talking about writing high-performance mode, threaded web socket server. He has.
So you got to add these kind of keywords because you know,
honestly the recruiters, they just, you know,
look for keywords and see if you look technical or not because they are the
ones that are going to do a first pass on your resume.
And if you can't pass them, then you're not going to get an interview.
And sometimes not going to lie, you're not going to read everything.
They're just going to be scanning for keywords.
So make sure you add as much jargon as possible, but also, you know,
be truthful. So yeah, so under projects, I didn't add that much,
but I did do extra things like, uh, did a lot of web projects. Uh,
I actually did also a hacked in North competition where I won,
to be honest, I don't think that really matters.
I don't think they even check that date,
mostly cared about my Citadel experience theater stuff or just bonus.
Oh my God. And I just remembered when I was at Citadel. Um,
I actually learned a lot because I also did a lot of side projects. Um,
maybe not a lot of side projects. I did one side project and it was actually a,
um, adult video streaming site.
And you don't ask me why I wanted to do that. Okay, fine.
You can ask me it's because I thought there was a lot of potential in that
market.
And I thought it was the best way to penetrate it using a very good tech,
but I did learn a lot from building those projects. Like for example,
I learned full-stack development. I learned about, you know,
how to use AWS ether, easy to S3 storage, CDNs,
like the whole stack to make a video streaming site. And it was pretty fast,
but I realized it was kind of costly. So then I decided to shut it down.
So yeah. So using that resume,
I applied everywhere and then I started interviewing,
let me just show you like a quick snapshot of all of the jobs
that I got offered. So, so I, once again, I got 10 interviews,
it seems like every term I just get 10 interviews, but, and then I get about,
let's see one, two, three, four, five, five offers and one ranked. Yeah.
So I got rejected by, you know, Amazon, Google, Microsoft really?
Oh,
this is for embedded software engineering and then Palintir technology not going
to lie. LinkedIn was not my first choice. Um, you know,
I would rather go to Google or Palentier, you know, then LinkedIn,
but you know, say levy. So yeah, as you can see 40 offers,
I had Coursera as a software engineer, infrastructure, LinkedIn,
Microsoft as a software engineer, Tinder, Yelp,
and I was ranked for Yext. So that was pretty funny.
There's a funny story about Tinder. I'm not sure if I should get into it,
but if ever if I ever edited this out, I'll just put it in D a patron page.
All right. So let's talk about the interview process for LinkedIn. So,
because I went to Waterloo and I was in the job mind system,
it was a lot easier.
All I had to do was to on-site interview and the people came to campus for that.
You would do one interview and then you would have a dinner together with all
the candidates. And then the day after, if you pass the first interview,
you're going to get the second interview. So let's talk about a first interview.
So the first interview,
my question was given a set of non negative integers and a
value.
Some determine if there is a subset of the given set who have some equal to
given some, for example, you have a set three 34,
four 12 five two,
and then the sum that they want is nine and a waiter output would be,
would be true. And then that subset would be four and five,
because if you add them together, you get nine. So easy dynamic programming.
So simple. I mean, if you want to solve it, you know, you could just,
you could just tell me what the answer is on a comment. I'll just pin it.
And yeah, there we go. I mean,
you could probably just Google it and find and figure that out.
I'm not gonna lie. I hadn't memorized.
Like I already knew about that problem before he asked me and I just pretended I
didn't know. I was like, Oh, what should I use?
And then first I used the recursive version because that's like the naive
version. And now I'm like, wait a minute. I could do it faster.
And then I did the dynamic programming version, but yeah,
it was all rehearsed for me. So it was great. Now the second interview,
the second interview was less of a coding interview.
It's more of an infrastructure and I think it depends what you specialize in
and then they would give you different interviews depending on that.
So let me tell you what a question is.
Basically the question asks you to design a fast key value store and it needs to
be support the function, get and put just like all key value stores. Okay.
And all the keys would fit in memory, but the valleys would be too large.
So you can't fit the whole thing, your whole key value store in memory.
Cause that would be too big. And you have two primitives,
you have a memory lookup structure. So kind of like a hash table.
And then also an append only file system.
Basically the whole point of this question is for you to think of a creative way
to use the memory hash map and the file system,
to be able to implement this key value store. In essence,
what you have to do is you have to put the keys in the memory hash map,
and then the values of the memory hash map would actually be the file number
and the offset. And then the actual value,
you can append that into a file. And then you use the value of the hash map,
which is the offset and the file number to actually get the real value in your
file system. Now,
the main constraint in this question is that in the file system,
it's append only. So when you write to a file, you can only append to it.
That means you cannot do random brights, but you could do random reads,
meaning you could choose an offset and then just read that value.
But you can't do that with, right. So that's the question.
I'm not going to go over it. Um, if I do, or if people really want the answer,
I'll just put it on my patron page. All right.
So now I'm going to talk about how it was working there.
Now let's talk about the work first. Uh,
let me just tell you that it was pretty chill.
I would come in at like 11:00 AM and then leave at like maybe
6:00 PM. Not even,
there's not as much pressure at LinkedIn then for example, Facebook or Citadel.
So what I did when I was there, I was on the graph team.
We wanted to make a whole new in memory graph database. So it was a lot faster.
Now what that graph database is supposed to do.
It's supposed to be the backend of all the queries that you do on LinkedIn.
So for example, uh, Facebook does it well,
but basically what we wanted to do is that we want to allow users to be able to
type queries, like friends of friends who never worked at Microsoft,
but worked at Facebook. So this was like a new project written from scratch.
And then the thing is the whole code base was in C plus plus.
So usually LinkedIn is like a Java shop, but just for this project,
it was in C plus plus because it's a high-performance language.
We could do a lot more low-level things, a lot easier. So it's pretty cool.
I did learn a lot about databases and, you know,
because we had to write everything from scratch, like, um, query optimizers,
you know, the query engine query persistence and stuff like that.
I worked on something very little,
which was query persistence is just using the graph database to persists all
the queries. And I don't remember clearly why I had to do that.
I remember there was a reason, but I kind of forgot, but, um,
but in the end they just scrapped it, uh, to be honest, like all,
all of my effort, it was, uh, it was pretty useless. So I got a return offer.
I was pretty happy about that. Unfortunately I did not return. And, um,
what I liked the most was more the social side of LinkedIn. So during my term,
it was, uh,
it was winter term and all of the interns came from university of Waterloo.
We were nine interns. Uh,
eight of us stayed in two apartments and there were next to each other.
So we would hang out all the time. It was so fun.
We would play Avalon like almost every night.
And it was a good bonding experience. And like, yeah,
it was the best internship because I built like long lasting friends and I still
talk to some of them now. And, uh, yeah, I really appreciate that.
And I even made like, um, kind of like a souvenir video,
it's kind of like a collage of what we did. I mean, I, I guess,
I guess I could show you a few clips.
Uh,
it's pretty funny. Cause, cause in some ways that's kind of what,
what made me start making videos, you know, after making this collage,
I kind of just made more and more videos made more, more collages.
And then in the end, like this is where I am now. I make videos for you guys.
Let's see, I remember this video is really cheesy.
Let me skip to that part.
Yeah.
I realized,
and for the first time in my life that not a single day, have I ever felt
miss the most? Oh yeah.
And this song was so popular back then.
Cause fast five was a fast five and then, sorry,
I think it was fast and furious seven just came out and uh,
or was it fast flying? I don't know. But basically the main actor died then.
Yeah. And I used this song.
Oh shoot.
Yeah. So these are all my interviews.
We've come a long way.
This was great. America hanging out there for awhile. It was real fun.
I live with this guy, actually.
I roomed with this guy. We were in the same room, but yeah,
this guy works at Snapchat now I think.
Anyways enough of that. All right. So I think that's about it.
Um, I hope that was useful for you. I hope you know, that was enjoyable.
Now if it was,
don't forget to press the light button and also if you're not subscribed
subscribe and also don't forget to press the bell so that you'll be notified
when the next video comes out.
And the next video after this would be a video about Facebook. But yeah.
Thanks again.